ils ont entre 13 et 14 ans ils seront
peut-être aux jeux olympiques de paris
en 2024 pour les aider à progresser le
club de gluants co organisait ce
dimanche 3 laissant au gymnase maurice
bac un tournoi baptisé horizon 2024 au
total 33 jeunes avec des rêves plein la
tête ont participé à ce rendez vous
j'aimerais bien y aller j'aimerais bien
aussi gagner aussi mais d'abord il faut
gagner cette profession là j'aurai moins
de choses déjà honoré en 2024
cette compétition qualificative pour les
championnats de france a surtout permis
à ces jeunes pépites venues de toute
l'île de france de peaufiner leurs
techniques de combat hausse à savoir
quand est-ce que l'adversaire va faire
basculer déjà ça serait bien et après on
va attaquer attaquer au bon moment
attaqué trop tôt je m'adapte ans en
fonction de ce qu'ils font s'ils vont
plus faire des attaques fume et à la
défense circule pas je verrai à l'attack
ce dimanche chaque participant a pu
prendre part une dizaine de combats mais
le chemin vers une médaille d'or aux
jeux olympiques est encore long selon
les coachs et a quand même beaucoup de
travail on verra s'ils arrivent à à
progresser et à continuer à leur
progression tout au long de leur vie
d'escrimeur et puis faut les accompagner
il faut voir là actuellement c'est
difficile à dire parce que c'est quand
on est quand même assez loin mais elle
travaille à faire c'est sûr et il ya du
potentiel aussi dans d'autres tournois
seront organisés à guyancourt d'ici 2024
pour former cette nouvelle génération la
mairie le club local ont signé un
partenariat